[Music]
yesterday President Obama appeared on
the view and he was grilled by the views
conservative co-hosts Elisabeth
Hasselbeck and I mentioned this on last
night's show let's take a look from last
night Elisabeth Hasselbeck
to ask the president a question I don't
know she won a reality shouldn't even
win no she was like fifty was on
Survivor a survivor
hey leader the free world answer this
[Applause]
all right well obviously we're a very
divided country right now so naturally
some people assume that I only went
after Elisabeth Hasselbeck because they
think I'm a liberal and I'm here to tell
you that is that is not true I'm
actually a registered anarchist I'm one
of the last members of the bull moose
party look it up kids it's important
stuff the points that I was making
though is this okay this was not a
partisan point I was making the point I
was making is this in my opinion a
reality show contestant should only be
allowed to question a sitting president
of the United States if and only if they
won their competition
[Applause]
that's why
yes I feel so strongly about this
tonight I am introducing the 28th
amendment to the US Constitution let's
get this thing passed here's the
language no person or persons who have
appeared on a reality television program
shall be allowed to question the
policies of a sitting president unless
said person or persons were the last
survivor on their island
the last tenant in their house the last
chef who used only the items found in
the pantry or the last Bachelorette who
was handed a red rose and got to marry
the douchebag
if you agree with me go to team koco.com
/ 28th amendment / huge waste of
everyone's time let's bring this country
together shall we
[Applause]